this week we got free cake cow cops and
human slingshot
oh that's wonderful I'm telling Emily
I'm not for that to me - it's a lake or
something oh yeah if it sounds like
something that used to do on Nickelodeon
guts I'm in god I remember that she was
a main Japanese man sleeping in a cabin
peacefully by himself if I didn't have
you seen that oh yeah usually I would
love to be on that thing did you how did
they get those guys to do it like do
they sign their life away hoping they
have like waivers and laws aleem I think
that's incredible news all right for our
first story it's all for the bits out
there it was all for the dead yeah my
man Brad first story there was the thief
that broke in - oh I guess she's
technically not a thief since he didn't
feel anything but he broke into the
bakery in China and they saw in the
surveillance footage that he was
comparing cakes and once he realized
that the cakes were just display cakes
he ended up just leaving it there and
left and so the cake owner or the bakery
owner what the [ __ ] the bakery owner was
saying that maybe it's because he
couldn't afford buying a cake and so she
she offered this man like she just sent
out a message out to the public like hey
this was you you know please come back
we're willing to give you a free cake
that's a Chinese truck that's what I
would say to get the guy yeah absolutely
cuz you didn't take anything you could
have easily broken into the cash
register but he didn't take you I'll
show you guys the surveillance footage
I like the sad music the media this guy
was so hungry but then you say no like
looking at the cakes and comparing them
trying to pick one which one will my
girlfriend like this one did you know
that they're fake not at that point
later on I guess he realized I don't
think I can't know I mean he just picked
it up it didn't even move he was like
yeah he was gonna eat the fake cake no
no but they're saying they're thinking
that maybe like he has a kid like me I
like how people make their own stories
yeah I feel like he was looking at it
he's like man all of this suck hungry or
homeless or anything like that
I'm so expensive looking back sure yeah
he doesn't necessarily need to be
homeless than not afford a cake but if
you're hungry I don't go for cakes no
exactly go for something more nutritious
yeah I want meat
I want [ __ ] corn on bread meat in the
corn school he wants a dessert that's
like oh I haven't eaten in three days
let me go get some Froyo dude you know
like that's not the that's not the
dessert is not that I know of starvation
and I have makes you hungrier yeah like
sugar always make me hungry or dude I
think I will choke for the K to be gonna
speak to my crazy yeah if you're
starving for like seven days you go for
cake for it was a joke [ __ ] oh we
thought you were serious you have a
sweet tooth yeah all right [ __ ] suck
I think the jokes to you guys know I
like it I was laughing thank you all
right
that's what you have see tickets do do
even happening soon laughing I love we
didn't want to invite you okay you
diffused them it worked
I was just trying to come back baby what
happened oh yeah you yeah maybe still if
I was it was my first UFC experience it
was great yeah if I was like hung if I
was hungry as [ __ ] I want some meats I
want some [ __ ] like grilled [ __ ]
veggies or something you know like your
smooth you're a captain like a desert
island or like in a survivor situation
well the world either
what's your first meal coming home Oh
what's your first meal anything that's
gonna give me diarrhea it's not diarrhea
it's not come enough you had diarrhea on
the island yeah but I need something
hearty like oh um oh we go on like maybe
grill them all which is like this badass
burger place or I don't girl them all
but the grill grill a walk around the
mall or like some beef stew type of [ __ ]
chicken potpie something hearty as a
[ __ ] how I could yeah
oatmeal or water and rice it's got
interesting like I feel like most people
when they get asked this question they
usually go to a food that they grew up
with mmm you know but you went as white
as possible I want something that's
gonna constipate me [ __ ] just plug
that [ __ ] ups I'm so hungry I don't want
it to pass through what about you what
would it be [ __ ] Taco Bell dude hyah
Oh I am a cheap I am that your children
food or absolutely how did you survive
an island and we offer you anything in
the world
and you and I wanted for the cheapest
[ __ ] out there because I'm trying to
save this money
no no it's well it's you know it's about
it's just that I would want talk about
if I can have anything and I say and the
fact that it's cheap but just is a is a
fact is that that you love growing yeah
yeah I agree
definitely what's your
my favorite alright my favorite
okay what's your go-to stop I do burrito
supreme yeah and I love but I love the
[ __ ] cheesy gordita crunch that
[ __ ] bro I'm like you look the tube is
my [ __ ] number six it's a number six
they come to two steak chalupas and a
sight crunchy taco and I would the thing
I love the most about the cheesy gordita
crunch is it's a traditional dish very
good Taco Bell tries too hard with their
extra flavors for no reason they win too
hard dude every other did the other ones
names I want to be tacos yes I like milk
chocolate people talk about this I like
dog food can I tell you why I like
they'll talk about what it still goes
back to Taco Bell because I like Bell
taco because I recreate the cheesy
gordita crunch with the del Taco
I know you're saying you guys go right
now and you gotta say that you like
gizzard hearts and [ __ ] no I like I like
taco bell's are good I like talking
about when they started [ __ ] putting
Doritos flavors so I always like the
supreme the taco supreme that [ __ ] was
good but once they put the [ __ ] Cool
Ranch and all that [ __ ] it just upgraded
it for me and that's why I hate Taco
Bell because it's [ __ ] with my
emotions wait wait wait they still have
that [ __ ] I know but that's why I hate
it because it's like Mickey you don't
want to love it I don't want to be
possible nothing got a [ __ ] taco
shell made out of chicken that's I
haven't tried that yet
it's a pro/con taco shell me not a fried
chicken dude and guess what it's
healthier than [ __ ] sorry there's this
really funny video of cops
catching these carjackers because one of
the woman involved here she was being
chased by a herd of cows
[Music]
[Music]
in the vehicle play with her Gary don't
stop [ __ ] right okay no offense say
good god you guys ain't gonna arrest me
usually like please these counts are
crazy yeah do they know what we're doing
to their kind the cows were like you
stole a car I know you did know the
owners are saying that there the cows
are probably being over protective of
their young because there was a little
no one got really really close to her
though yeah they didn't do so no cows
are Brian don't trip I'm doing a shirt
around it's awful on the ground are
shaking she want me do oh my god whoa
what I've never seen bags like that
before in my life dude it looks like her
face is melting dude her bags up bags
yeah dude that's crazy yeah
Jahannam she looks sad eyes if you put
never slept ever in your life in
Wikipedia right now that's the picture
that would pop up hi Rach you look like
an evil villain yeah I've never seen a
widow's peak fade away like that before
you that easy on hair jokes that has
meth written all over it
I know it does you know I used to be a
big fan of those as a kid you know
Spanish bull guys oh yeah until I saw
what happens to them like yeah dude if
they have a long sword they find when
they tired and he go right into their
spine and they kill them I was like oh
[ __ ] I let they lived it's pretty much
and so that hope the red stuff I thought
it was paint you know they say they
paint the bull but it's their blood it's
a slow death - they stabbed them once
and then again and again over and over
and I used to like watching the people
running away from the ball because when
people get picked up on their butt and
then thrown into the air that was so
funny love those videos you see it what
people are like your father live I love
it
and then the Bulls come in they flew and
they toss them to the side and you see
people [ __ ] fly crazy how strong
they're you know like that sometimes get
caught like in their thigh the horn gets
kinda cool shake them off and then
they're just like that's hilarious
that's funny
oh man well cuz it's like you did it
it's it's sad when it's like an accident
like oh you were just standing there and
a bull [ __ ] punctured your testicle
or some [ __ ]
no but the guys who wear like bloodline
hats is are running with the Bulls yeah
I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] so you signed
up or this is what you asked for
and then they always look so surprised
when they get [ __ ] take it down when
you signed up this is what you yeah you
literally know that yeah that's why it's
really funny I don't know that's why
it's so funny there's these videos that
I've been watching in South Africa it's
pretty [ __ ] sick it's crazy they have
these like private police groups there
now that run around would straight up
like aks and all that stuff and I
thought this was the police out there
but after research it's not but when
there's a carjacking or anything like
that happening
they just these private police guys just
come up and just run up on the bad guys
with freaking machine guns and
yeah it's pretty it's pretty much they
just like mow them down with it like I
said this was funny no no it was a
carjacking just kind of reminder that
because recently everyone evideos and
then you're like and then they have
eighty or forty sevens they take
families out of there don't you know but
it reminded me of these videos that I've
been watching because of like you know
so you know like they have the infrared
and heating and now they're like this is
how we take down bad guys but in South
Africa that's how they take down bad
guys it's never I told you guys my
friend who worked out in Tanzania how
the people around them the guys soul
will try to steal a cell phone off he
was on a scooter or something and he
trying to steal somebody's cell phone
they threw rocks in that fell off they
grabbed him put him into a stack of
tires and burned him alive whoa you mean
the village got together and yeah the
people did that instead of tires no no
no it's just like no I must have been
really stealing in town those reasons I
was do terrible any for some reason like
I guess like specifically stealing a
cell phone it's like trying to steal
somebody's life life life hey yank oh
that one yeah and so hey literally burn
that guy alive into scatter after like
that was fun yeah yeah it's just like in
guys who's crazy cuz he said like after
they burned him alive like everybody
just kind of went about their way it's
like so what are we doing for dinner
guys yeah we're go to your house to
grill all right oh yes yeah it's like
I'm in the mood for grill to now [ __ ]
you may be doing it for work man it's
[ __ ] crazy
so don't steal in Tanzania that's the
life yeah basically don't get home so
steal very good that's a good tip for
everybody isn't there like places like
India where if you do steal get your
hand cut off or whatever is that like
ancient law and I still have it I think
that's real okay do they have those
snake things to it the snake charmers
right that's yeah that's that's real
berroco really shits real
was it cold breasts I don't know it's
trying not to look at except bad for the
animal did he do that song or is that
copy written can then I use that because
of a good DMCA I know alright last story
here there's this crazy new thing in New
Zealand where they're catapulting humans
pretty much hell yeah anyways I mean
they this looks so much biggest canopy
we should go to New Zealand I got
friends out there here we go
[Music]
this kick-started music I know alright
it's all motivation whoa what the hell
is this oh no like a sip wine okay I'll
actually pull you into the valley I'm
down what the [ __ ]
nope
oh wait so what's the difference between
like a bungee nope nope no cool so how'd
you go back just swing backwards in the
Sun catches me really I did this a
couple years ago I'd like to see called
it bungy not that's the company oh it's
not a human catapult just a new way of
saying I thought no a catapult to me
when you get thrown in the air hmm like
you're on a [ __ ] machine and it's
like slingshot slingshot would be a we
are calling it more like this thing shot
yeah yeah cuz I did that at six nights
with Shane Dawson's brother couple years
ago we were both strapped into this
thing and we got pulled up like this
you're just looking at the [ __ ]
ground you're totally like horizontal
with the ground and then they let you go
and you swing like exactly like that
yeah I see no but yeah for that one
though they just released this one that
shot you're only knew like oh I want to
do that pantsless and then like when we
go three two one I must drink a lot of
water and just pee as I'm [ __ ] oh
we're gonna like shower yourself
no no yesterday the peas going this way
good if you're peeing like this you're
hitting the PIO whole way down the whole
time hey cuz you're gonna move faster
than the stream of water comin up I was
really good to a scientist he's like
it's like we're hitting a feeding yeah
yeah give me a pison on here what if I
bend my dick backwards like this you
can't touch your dick Oh
how would you bend your dick I've got
evidence I push it down my hair like
this I think you could do it then you
know we'll get between my legs and
between my legs is gonna go I think
what's gonna happen you're gonna fidei
your own [ __ ] with your piss
you know Joe like [ __ ] with or on the
[ __ ] so that's for sure don't mind it
I know but this is not a sexual I like
this shoulder shrug
it's a pee-pee propeller I wanted to do
a pee-pee propellant is it for you is it
about disrespecting the land or is it
about actual feeling feeling feeling
it's it's it's I just thought it's a
funny image and it's a good feeling
because it's like you're gonna be
relaxed or just oh my god right like
that that no it'll be like your body's
gonna tense up with the adrenaline but
the pees gonna relax while you're in
adrenaline so it's even it's kind of
countering it yeah it's like it's like
doing some coke when you're drunk you
count around back
yeah I'm you in the middle I'm
depressant I wouldn't be able to do that
alone yes because I wouldn't make the
walk so you watching the video I get it
golf carts up there like a drag go
across that bridge with her oh [ __ ] dude
like I I can't
that's [ __ ] wild it let's go
blindfolded like you don't even oh my
god that was he so scared
that's the worst tell you when they like
easier because you're just feeling it
now you know here's the worst part of it
is when you're up there cuz this is the
worst part for being one man me and
Jared we're up there and you're looking
at the ground and you don't know exactly
when they're they're pulling they don't
tell you that's the worst part you're
the one that does it or at least when I
did it because L think maybe that's what
it was years old I think you're right I
think you're right but it's the waiting
part the waiting part to me is the most
psychologically [ __ ] for that food part
yeah because I'm just like oh I'll just
do it I don't know what's gonna happen
that's what case you're saying about
when you guys went skydiving you say
there was way scarier in the plane going
I like to anticipation and in the plane
that's going up the doors open so you
just slow yourself leaving the floor
well when you get up there they're like
oh and by the time you do the sky like
that part still enjoyable perfect line
up was too scary really the opposite
like that was way more
on the floor like on the ground yeah
then the higher up we got like the more
calming welcome almost dying it's so fun
mmm
the adrenaline like that experience yeah
action that happen in your mind but when
I see so much safety equipment and all
that stuff and it seems like smart
people built it I have so much trust in
it I don't know what it was if that if
that if that thing was made in like was
was in China
I'd be scared here's the thing I hear
the words equipment and I think okay
good and then I look at it and it's
[ __ ] ropes and I'm like yeah give me
equipment if you guys are ever in New
Zealand you want to do this
it's 172 US dollars you don't get to go
gv2 miles an hour inches 1.5 seconds and
you're 409 feet up dude that's faster
that's a supercar speed 1.5 second as
fast as particular that is yeah sure so
excited that's crazy yeah I'm not doing
how are you maybe at least 13 years old
and weigh at least 60 pounds a 13 year
old oh that's a 55 pounds I like I like
doing things like this button you know
I'm kind of surprised for somebody who's
such an adrenaline junkie and only finds
like real stimulation doing extreme
things that you don't do coke they want
you to cook - because you need such high
stimulus you know you so I'm surprised
that you don't do a lot more hardcore
drugs other than water other than all
that drugs beyond that you do you can't
talk about cuz all your brand deals but
we will talk about it off camera like we
always do we talk about it ruin every
brand know that she has [ __ ] de me
knows I'm trying to help I'm trying to
protect her [ __ ] don't worry what else
you soon I first of all a lot of people
[ __ ] in Walmart so let's you know I
online job you just took a [ __ ] on one
where I know
[Music]
[Music]